très bien merci je sens mon coeur je te
comportes aux pauvres que ce soit en
termes vestimentaire eux physiquement
ses cheveux son attitude sa prestance
franchement il ya tout qui va vraiment
eu moyen on dirait et j'ai un truc je
crois que tu en lien avec les yeux de
l'amour oui si rapidement ma foi
ça fait quatre mois 4 bon j'ai pas le
temps moi vous savez moi j'ai deux
femmes à marier
quoi c'est
direct c'est assez directe où tout va
trop vite
l'asam blocks je sais pas j'avais pas lu
cros par rapport à son métier son métier
ça fait peur parce que non la séduction
quand même merci alexandre de la
bastille à vous ben non ça me fait
plaisir bah pas tranquille tout va bien
vous bon on va revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé hier alors quel métier est si
problématique pour pauline
fichiers vous le savez
connaissait d'ailleurs le métier
problématique également des personnes
autour de la table la montagne n
mais vous avez dit je savais pas que ça
existait on va regarder ça et c'est un
truc de fou parce que ça peut ça peut
intéresser peut-être benjamin castaldi
le rapport à ton métier ça je m'étends
paraît oui je suis assez connus sur un
réseau social ont-ils de contenu c'est
je teste les couples où on m'envoie un
message en me disant est ce que tu peux
tester ma compagne est ensuite moi j'ai
dragué jeu par âge par la guerre chez un
grand séducteur et je suis fier de moi
parce que je sais très bien comment ça
marche hélas beaucoup de commentaires
assez chaud et en plus sur les réseaux
sociaux sans le système parler aux
femmes
admettons jeudi d'arrêter les réseaux
parce que tu le ferais ou pas
j'ai pâtir oui je maintiens mon âge s'il
ya des raisons valables si ça peut être
que bénéfique pour nous
parfois c'est mon couple à bord ont
coupé avant le reste forcément à alex
way incroyable ton métier c'est vrai je
n'envie ouais c'est bien mais tu gagnes
vraiment de l'osec ça ben moi je dis pas
que c'est mon métier bon honnêtement
j'ai arrêté les coûts les études cette
année c'est quoi j'étais en faculté de
droit ah ouais quand même ouais pas
arrêté pour des raisons ba s'était pas
fait pour moi ben pas fait pour toi
comme moi
et après
ouais à côté jeu complet volontaire et
voilà en plus des réseaux sociaux du
coin mais c'est pas je peux moi pour moi
cependant mes chers occupé qu'en fait tu
testes la fidélité les well et fidélité
des hommes et des femmes est ce que tu
veux remplir une mission peut être pour
moi de donner un nom de code s à théo
donc quand tu feras en contact avec
alors le garçon la fim envoie un message
en privé en me demandant si elle peut
tester où il peut tester texans
semblaient pas ça d'accord et a donc du
coup moi j oui pourquoi pas ouais et
après ouais j'en vois ndm-1 et tu as eu
des surprises quelques années
maintenant mais il dit quoi sur ndm vous
dites quoi ça dépend comment ça me
renvoie la branche est un peu magasin je
crois qu'il va dire mais je n'ai pas
fait qu a annoncé après le cdj innover
dans chaque histoire fait plusieurs
façons de juniac voilà non mais oui
jusqu'où vous allez qu'on vous testez
les couples est ce que vous allez
jusqu'à passer à l'acte non non non hd
que pour moi j'estime qu'il ya tromperie
ou du moins il ya quelque chose à
reprocher je screen et j'en envoie
directement à la personne qui m'envoyait
tester est ce que l'on te paye pour le
faire ah oui on m'a déjà proposé en mai
après jamais accepté la masia qui fait
ça gratos ouais ah ouais c'est cool ça
reste pour tester la fidélité c'est fou
dingue mais maintenant qu'il est courant
à la télé ce sera plus possible mais
c'est vrai j'ai pensé aussi mais alors
que non mais tu changeras aussi qu'il a
un profil ouais je sais pas mais je vais
trouver une foule inquiète pas on
retrouvera et quand une femme se demande
de tester la fidélité de son compagnon
comment vis-à-vis du compagnon j'ai un
compte fille secret
tu vois les bleus
[Rires]
nous le donne et hors antenne seydoux
qui se dit consciente mais voilà pas
rater moi je suis toujours professionnel
alexandre
testeurs de poule sur les réseaux
sociaux que tu sois et et et voilà
qu'il savait provenir des tec poli oui
[Rires]
la beauté qu'est ce que tu as
très bien dit la vérité bernard montiel
tout va bien non je trouve ça formidable
semble
complètement fou
trimestre s'est pas tu as parlé pendant
la pub non cela ne l'est pas
alors alexandre they take pollini requis
très très joli aussi un très beau coup
ouais
tu étais histoire de goût et donc c'est
vrai que ça lui a posé problème est ce
que au final vous avez surmonter ce
problème êtes vous encore ensemble on
regarde
j'ai réfléchi
je nous laisser une chance
j'étais club école des sentiments
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vraiment ce que je veux entendre
elle veut à veut du concret a battu
sérieux m days nous laisse une chance
toi tu as passons
j'ai tellement de bien
chaleureuse
moment là
entre alexandrie collins et elle est
déjà terminée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je passais haye s'est passé des choses
en interne fait j'ai appris des choses
on à terre ne veux pas le savoir
à la gare de l'inter comment dire en
fait j'ai soupçonner quelque chose faite
de son côté sa fidélité ouais par
rapport à ça et donc du coup plutôt que
me prendre la tête j'ai préféré mettre
directement à terre mais voilà après il
s'est avéré au final que c'était
totalement faux
je me dis que c'était trop tôt pour ce
genre de problème bon je me prenne la
tête avec ce genre de choses étudiez
bien quand même à lire oui oui alors ces
morts là mais ouais
parce que je trouve qu'il y avait bien
le tribun est ce qu'il aimerait tester
le couple d'origine moi sûrement voix
seulement voilà bagages tout va bien
merci
pas mal ah oui oui bien sûr et c'est un
boulot et je peux tester le couple
obenheim aussi patoche
avec tant d'autres comptes par contre si
tu testes de samedi aura beaucoup de
gens testez vous savez avant il y avait
ce qu'on appelait un constat d'adultère
ça qu'on fait on envoyait un missile
6 heures du matin lui l'a fait
apparemment jetée témoignages les
schémas et pour constater qu'il y avait
un
temps été ensemble 3d c'est un peu
pareil enfin on cesse d'être
génial ce soir djibril fall je
m'enrichis de garder alex je trouve que
vous n'êtes pas sur la rupture parce que
vous avez dans l'émission vous dit
quelque chose d'ordre privé là vous
dites vous soupçonniez quelque chose non
mais qu'est ce que c'est parce qu'elle
est sur les réseaux très active aussi
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui vous a
gince que dites nous la vérité ce
qu'elle a fait elle avait participé un
truc aussi par rapport aux réseaux à
ces deux là en fait qu'il ya eu des
soupçons par rapport au fait qu'elle
soit on peut rapprocher d'une autre
personne j'ai rien compris
incroyable mais si elle s'est rapprochée
à part vendu nos commerciaux
des photos les peurs du coup
permettez-nous de douter de votre
sincérité quand vous participer à cette
émission parce qu'au final tu te rends
compte tu t'es trompé sur la personne et
quel mot n'a pas été infidèle avec toi
pas aller plus loin et du coup roulé les
morceaux alors qu'elle t'a fait une
jolie déclaration pendant l'émission
elle et a dit qu'elle voulait de toi
ensuite eu la soupçonne quelque chose
qu'elle n'a pas fait il revient pas vers
elle c'est ça que je voulais mais après
il ya plein de choses qui vont faire que
dia la distance aux sceptiques
elle habite ou bourgogne bourgogne où ça
nous fera
après le fait de tester la fidélité pour
tous les coûts parce que toi ça trois
parades possibles des déformations
l'impossible est possible après cible
aussi
puisqu'il croyait qu elle jeta mal à
tromper un tu croyais on m'a apporté d
un coup pensé quoi le donc ça tombe bien
tu vas continuer à tester les couples ou
pas ouais je le fais je le fais un peu
moins ces derniers temps mais je le fais
quoi je rencontre jamais mêlé à ce qu
ils rencontrent ils rencontrent jamais
dit non non ça va vous servir
vous l'avez dit faisait mal aux garçons
vous l'avez déjà fait dans le cas
quand il sent que ça arrive il fait une
capture
rencontre ont alors été moindre mais il
est endormi de paléo revenir dans
l'émission vous inquiétez pas raison le
parminou mais voilà si un cinquième
alex en tête et comment lens moment tu
es célibataire fait quoi
bon des gens que tu as compris la
question pas
si gentiment c'est qu'elle a répondu
c'est mon pote non non il a très bien
compris la question
si compliqué non quoi pas de quoi non
et
ça n'est jamais mort moi
ce n'était pas la ténéré
à téléch lui voilà
les professionnels y garde l'oeil ouvert
pour son événement non non je prends la
coupe maintenant comme
ça qu'est ce que t'as bouquet ce que je
réponds à la question est comment
voyez qu'il a un problème ce garçon 04
pose la même question idéologique dont
la pose la même question à dire aux gens
te regardent il va être clair l'ue
résidant lui
sabrina
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas célibataire je la sais qu'il
est
sûr de quoi en même temps que son
souhait est sur deux coups en même temps
voilà non non
3,5 et les
alcools et coupes il cache quelque chose
ah oui du coup moi je teste les coupes
[Rires]
malade aussi
c'est quoi aussi j'ai connu ses moments
de
la vingtaine ont plus fait alors oui bon
des moments de flottement
j'ai toujours eu des moments où
je flotte pour la question d'avoir genre
mon truc mon projet monica changer
d'emploi êtes célibataire
[Applaudissements]
vous avez compris la question
sinon ça va déjà répondu à cette
question lorsque votre coeur est pris
bah oui oui oui oui mon coeur est pris à
oui oui j'aurais peut-être corps et
votre tête à tête
les prises oui par l'argent
le travail oui ce que vous avez à
nouveau et zizi
[Musique]